[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen den Sport
hat Sven fast für Sie auch von mir einen
schönen guten Abend als erstes schauen
wir ausführlich ins marokkanische
Katastrophengebiet
schweres Erdbeben in Marokko mindestens
1000 Menschen sterben unter den Trümmern
werden noch viele Opfer befürchtet
G20-Gipfel in Indien die Staatschefs
äußern sich zum Krieg in der Ukraine
nehmen die Afrikanische Union auf und
beschließen ein riesiges
Infrastrukturprojekt
und royaler Glanz in Deutschland Prinz
Harry eröffnet die Invictus Games in
Düsseldorf und ist heute Abend zu Gast
im Aktuellen Sportstudio
[Musik]
weltweit ist die Anteilnahme groß nach
dem verheerenden Erdbeben in Marokko
mehr als 1030 Menschen sind ums Leben
gekommen mehr als 1200 verletzt worden
und die Opferzahlen werden wohl noch
weiter steigen denn es langsam zeigt
sich das ganze Ausmaß des Erdbebens nach
US-Angaben hat es die Stärke 6,8
das Beben traf Marokko um kurz nach 23
Uhr Ortszeit mit dem Epizentrum im
Atlasgebirge dort sind noch immer viele
Bergdörfer nicht erreichbar doch das
betroffene Gebiet ist noch deutlich
größer auch in den Städten Agadir und
Wasser satt und in der Tourist
Marrakesch gibt es Tote und Verletzte
dort beginnt der Bericht von Christoph
Marrakesch in der historischen Altstadt
der Moment als alle Märkten Gefahr nur
weg Fluchtinstinkt alle Rennen nur wohin
in den engen Gassen also hin und her
während von oben die ersten
trümmerfallen gemeinsam mit ihrem Mann
erlebt die Urlauberin Yvonne Friedrich
die dramatischen Sekunden auf der
Dachterrasse seiner barlos ist was genau
ein paar Sekunden war ich eben
tatsächlich gegenüber das Gebäude reißen
und eben teilweise auch Teile
runterstürzen
da gucken sich die Menschen an und es
überlegten alle und plötzlich fangen
alle auf und liest zwar legt sich die
erste Panik schnell trotz seines
Nachgebens nach 20 Minuten doch
angespannt und ratlos irren Anwohnern
Touristen durch die Straßen drin
schlafen für viele undenkbar derweil
fühlen sich schnell die
krankenhaushäuser in fast allen Städten
hier westlich von Marrakesch aber selbst
bis hoch zum Meer hunderte Kilometer im
Norden
[Musik]
dann stürzte mein Haus zur Hälfte ein
schnell beginnt der Kampf um die die es
nicht bis zur Tür geschafft haben
verletzte aber auch tote werden geborgen
nachts Tags und immer noch
in einem Ort am Fuß des Atlasgebirges
nah am Epizentrum muss eine
Baggerschaufel ein ganzes Haus abstützen
die Helfer können nur ahnen wie viele
unten eingeschlossen sind und wissen
noch fast nichts über die Dörfer in den
Bergen weiter südlich ein Bewohner
meldet verzweifelt über soziale Medien
tote auch bei uns Samstagvormittag und
noch immer keine Hilfe in Sicht derweil
waren Geologen der Boden bleibt
gefährlich nachdem so ein starkes Leben
aufgetreten ist gibt es eben
spannungsumlagerungen und es kann auch
passieren dass es noch weitere stärkere
Beben gibt Marokko schwer gezeichnet wer
kann spendet Blut und langsam wird immer
klarer dass sehr viele Verletzte sehr
viel Hilfe brauchen werden
und vorm Flughafen im Marrakesch steht
für uns anna-arend Anne wir erleben Sie
die Situation ich bin tatsächlich gerade
erst hier rausgekommen und einer der
Bank mit denen ich gesprochen habe der
sagte zu mir es ist so traurig und
tatsächlich so das Leben hat Panik
ausgelöst das wahrscheinlich kaum einer
damit gerechnet zu haben dass du etwas
passieren kann
Nordafrika relativ fand doch gar nicht
so tief unter der Erde statt dachte dann
halt Kilometer was gering ist was es
besonders gefährlich macht und die
Folgen natürlich besonders dramatisch
quasi stündlich steigen ja auch die
Opferzahlen woran liegt es denn das
bisher noch gar nicht das ganze Ausmaß
dieser Katastrophe abzusehen ist das
wird tatsächlich
befürchtet dass die Zahl leider noch
weiter steigen wird wir sind ja jetzt
hier in Marrakesch hier wo ich stehe
kann man jetzt nicht sehen aber in der
Altstadt Medina ist sehr viel verstört
und das ist auch noch 70 km vom
Epizentrum entfernt das liegt im
Atlasgebirge da waren wir selber auch
gar nicht so lange Zeit Dreharbeiten
über
Weltkulturerbestätten und ich kann
wirklich berichten dass der Zugang
unglaublich schwer ist das sind steile
sehr enge Straßen teilweise
schulterpisten und das macht natürlich
jetzt die Arbeit für die Rettungskräfte
extrem schwer danke schön und die
schlechte Tonqualität bitten wir zu
entschuldigen
Interview haben wir aus technischen
Gründen vor einer halben Stunde
aufgezeichnet
angesichts der Erdbebenkatastrophe
laufen in vielen Ländern wie Deutschland
die Vorbereitungen auf Hochtouren
Rettungskräfte und Hilfslieferungen nach
Marokko zu schicken auch in Deutschland
bangen viele um Angehörige und Bekannte
die sie in Marokko haben die meisten
deutsch-marokanischen Menschen leben in
Nordrhein-Westfalen in Düsseldorf hat
Martin Schiffler heute einige getroffen
hinterm Düsseldorfer Hauptbahnhof
pulsiert das marokkanische Herz
Nordrhein-Westfalens fast 6000 Menschen
mit marokkanischen Wurzeln leben hier im
sogenannten magrettviertel viele von
ihnen haben Opfer zu beklagen Verwandte
oder Freunde fast jeder hier kennt wohl
jemanden der direkt betroffen ist also
ich habe mit eine Frau heute morgen
gesprochen dass ich unsere Nachbarin die
hat zwei Brüder der auch gestorben sind
die sind unterm Trümmer ihre ältere
Mutter
die war krank und die war am schlafen
und die ist leider auch gestorben sie
haben auch Leute verloren die sind
gestorben und heute morgen hat sie
wieder angerufen die haben gesagt dass
du so viele Torte wir machen uns einen
großen Sorge für viele Leute sind noch
unterwegs
vom Hilfswerk Aktion Media bei Krefeld
klingelt seit dem Erdbeben das Handy
fast pausenlos sie sondieren die Lage
und packen gerade Medikamente fürs
Erdbebengebiet ein in dieser Halle
lagern Sie das ganze Jahr über damit das
Hilfswerk schnell auf Notfälle wie
diesen reagieren kann Kollegen von uns
sind auf dem Weg ins Erdbebengebiet ich
selbst werde mich morgen auf dem Weg
dorthin machen und wir werden dann
schauen wie die Bedarfe sind aber es ist
eigentlich jetzt schon klar dass die
Menschen das Nötigste brauchen Nahrung
Wasser Kleidung schutzhygiene
die Hilfsbereitschaft weltweit ist groß
wenn auch Sie den Menschen in Marokko
helfen wollen das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe nimmt ihre Spende
gerne an die IBAN laute.de 65 100 400
400 600 100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Marokko infos auch unter
spenden.zdf.de und den ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
jetzt schauen wir nach Indien dort
treffen sich derzeit die G20 also die
führenden Industrie- und Schwellenländer
sowie die Europäische Union obwohl der
Gipfel noch nicht zu Ende ist und es
große inhaltliche Differenzen zwischen
den Mitgliedern gibt einigte man sich
heute auf eine Abschlusserklärung das
freut besonders Gastgeber Indien mehr
aus Neu Delhi von MRT wissen
ausgerechnet der Gott der Zerstörung
wacht über diesen Gipfel aber Shiva
erschafft so die indische Mythologie aus
dem Ende auch das neue und das ist für
den Gastgeber eine Weltordnung die sich
an den Menschen ausrichtet nicht an den
alten Mächten vielleicht hat er das Joe
Biden vor dem Rat der Zeit erklärt seit
heute gehört formell auch die
Afrikanische Union zum Kreis der
eigentlich jetzt g21 der globale Süden
hält den Ukraine Krieg nicht für das
wichtigste Thema auch wenn Modi ihn
wenigstens erwähnt der Krieg habe die
Vertrauenskrise in der Welt weiter
vertieft aber wenn wir kobit besiegen
konnten dann werden wir auch gegen diese
Krise siegreich sein sagt er wieder
gemischt fällt dann die überraschend
früher Abschluss Erklärung aus in ihr
die Formel kein Staat darf Gewalt an
drohen oder anwenden um Gebiete entgegen
der territorialen Integrität
Souveränität und Unabhängigkeit eines
Staates zu erobern
Freude über eine Selbstverständlichkeit
aber dafür rufen Sie dazu auf die
russland-sanktionen aufzuweichen damit
Moskau wieder nahrungs- und Düngemittel
in die Welt liefern kann trotzdem
Zufriedenheit komme ich deshalb zum
Ergebnis dass das gut ist und ein Erfolg
weil das
lange nicht sich abgezeichnet hat dass
wir so weit kommen dann kündigen die USA
die EU und andere Partner noch ein
riesiges Infrastrukturprojekt an ein
Gegengewicht zu Chinas Seidenstraße
Eisenbahn und Schiffslinien sollen
Indien den Nahen Osten und Europa eng
miteinander verbinden und so feiern sie
nun hier dass dieser Gipfel zumindest
nicht gescheitert ist
und dass nur die ist mir jetzt Andreas
kühners zugeschaltet Andreas zeigt die
Abschlusserklärung eher die
Gemeinsamkeiten oder die
Meinungsverschiedenheiten innerhalb der
G20
ganz klar letzteres dieser Erklärung
führt vor allem dem Westen vor Augen wie
tief der Graben inzwischen ist zum
sogenannten globalen Süden beim letzten
G20-Gipfel in Bali haben sich die
Staaten noch auf eine scharfe
Verurteilung Russlands geeinigt und hier
heute in Neu-Delhi ist das wirklich nur
mit Ach und Krach gelungen eine
Selbstverständlichkeit zu betonen den
Grundsatz der territorialen Integrität
obwohl die Präsidenten Russlands und
Chinas gar nicht hier sind ist es ihnen
gelungen die Position ja im Prinzip der
halben Welt aufzuweichen und das nachdem
der Westen nachdem auch Bundeskanzler
Scholz ganz persönlich die
Wackelkandidaten unter den G20 Staaten
im vergangenen Jahr bereits quatscht ja
zum Teil auch beschenkt hat Stichwort
Infrastruktur Initiative das überhaupt
ein Papier entstanden ist das 20 Staaten
unterzeichnen können darunter auch
Russland und die USA das ist sein Erfolg
aber das ist der Erfolg der Gastgeber
hier Indien danke für diese Einschätzung
Andreas
in Russland gehen in den nächsten Tagen
die regional- und Kommunalwahlen zu Ende
abgestimmt wird in weiten Teilen des
Landes unter anderem über gouvernance
posten und Regionalparlamente auch in
den von Russland besetzten ukrainischen
gebeten Lohans John jetzt saporicia und
hasson wurden die Menschen aufgefordert
ihre Stimme abzugeben die Ukraine und
auch die Bundesregierung verurteilen das
als scheinbaren Christian sem berichtet
wählen vor der Haustür in den von
Russland besetzten Regionen in der
Ukraine der Kreml tut alles für eine
hohe Wahlbeteiligung und alles soll
aussehen wie bei einer echten Wahl
russland will mit der Abstimmung dort
Normalität zugerieren aller
internationaler Kritik zum Trotz diese
sogenannten Wahlen in den besetzten
Gebieten der Ukraine haben keine
rechtliche Grundlage
nicht nur in den besetzten Regionen auch
in Russland wird gewählt neue Kreml
Treue Gouverneure Bürgermeister
Regionalparlamente ohne wirkliche
Gegenkandidaten die Opposition in
Russland wurde in den letzten Jahren
kaltgestellt in Moskau gilt der Sieg von
Bürgermeister sobianin als sicher
Wahlplakate sieht man kaum in der Stadt
ich kenne keine Kandidaten es gibt keine
Werbung für die Kandidaten als gäbe es
nur einen Kandidaten den alle kennen und
der gewählt werden muss
kurz vor den Wahlen gab es auch neue
Repressionen diesmal gegen die
unabhängigen Wahlbeobachter der
Organisationen gollos
die Überwachungsmöglichkeiten sind in
den letzten Jahren stark eingeschränkt
worden das heißt es ist jetzt fast
unmöglich geworden die Wählerstimme zu
schützen
die Wahlbeobachter sagen noch nie war
Putins Russland so weit entfernt von
freien und Fähren Wahlen wie heute bei
den Regionalwahlen in Moskau vor vier
Jahren gab es noch Demonstrationen auf
den Straßen weil unabhängige Kandidaten
nicht zugelassen wurden solche Proteste
sind heute in Russland wegen der
Repressionen undenkbar geworden
gewarnt wird auch vor Manipulationen bei
der elektronischen Abstimmung Präsident
Putin gab seine Stimme heute
demonstrativ am Computer ab
nach Deutschland mehrere Verbände
fordern das gestern im Bundestag
verabschiedete sogenannte heizungsgesetz
nachzubessern ein ausreichende Förderung
des Einbaus emissionsfreie Heizungen
müssen nun zügig kommen und dauerhaft
für private Eigentümer zugänglich sein
so der Präsident des eigentümerverbands
Haus und Grund Warnecke der Deutsche
Mieterbund forderte eine höhere
Förderung beim Mietwohnungen
wenn junge jüdische Menschen bedroht
gemobbt geschlagen werden wenn Jude als
Schimpfwort gilt und wenn es auf
Pausenhöfen antisemitische Gewalt gibt
dann ist klar Schulen in Deutschland
haben ein Problem eines das auch ein
Problem mangelnder Bildung ist darauf
machen der Zentralrat der Juden und die
Bundesregierung aufmerksam und Steuern
dagegen mit einem Projekt das Vorurteil
abbauen soll Stephanie gagus berichtet
drei Jüdinnen erzählen über ihren Alltag
vor Schülerinnen und Schülern der
otto-lilienthal-gemeinschaftsschule in
Erfurt Miete Joe heißt das Projekt Thema
auch Antisemitismus und zwar wollte ich
gerne wissen ob wir selber schon Gewalt
Erfahrungen habt tatsächlich ist vor
unserer Schule passiert wir standen
draußen und dann kam auf einmal ein Mann
vorbei und er hat den jungen neben uns
gefragt ob er eine Zigarette hätte
meinte er nein eine Freundin von mir
meinte ich habe aber eine und sie hatte
einen Stern meinte der Mann einfach ja
ich rede nicht mit dir du Jude jeden Tag
passiert so etwas oder ähnliches an
Schulen Antisemitismus mal von rechts
getarnt als Kritik an Israel oder von
verschwörungsideologen wieder mit
umgegangen wird hängt immer noch vom
persönlichen Einsatz der Lehrkräfte ab
und Projekttagen wie diesen meiner
Meinung nach ist das
antisemitismus-problem ein
Bildungsproblem das heißt es müsste
eigentlich schon in der Ausbildung der
Lehrkräfte angesetzt werden bisher gibt
es keine bundesweit einheitliche
Ausbildung nun aber bewegen sich die
Kultusminister überarbeiten etwas
Schulbücher zusammen mit dem Zentralrat
der Juden und auch die Qualifizierung
des Lehrpersonals dass wir sagen wir
haben eine Sensibilisierung im
Bewusstsein bei den pädagogischen
Mitarbeitern führt das Thema wir haben
den Mut und auch ein klares Verfahren
wie wir Vorfälle von Antisemitismus an
den Schulen melden Lehrerausbildung
Schulbücher Meldepflicht beim Thema
Antisemitismus in den Schulen muss
Deutschland dringend nacharbeiten
Millionen Tonnen Müll landen jährlich in
den Meeren angeschwemmt auch aus unseren
Flüssen 10.000 freiwilliger haben heute
etwas dagegen getan beim Aktionstag Ryan
clean ab sammelten sie entlang des
Rheinufers den Müll ein und auch an
vielen anderen deutschen Flüssen oder
angepackt am Plastikmüll verenden pro
Jahr zahllose Meerestiere und Vögel
in Düsseldorf findet heute zum ersten
Mal in Deutschland ein Sport Ereignis
statt das so viel mehr ist als Sport den
Weg des Games ein Wettbewerb etwa für
kriegsversehrte Soldaten und Soldaten
nennen mehr als 500 Menschen aus aller
Welt messen sich in Disziplinen wie
Rudern laufen Bogenschießen und schöpfen
so auch wieder Kraft fürs Leben
schließlich heißt Invictus unbesiegt mit
dabei Prinz Harry der das Ganze vor
Jahren gründete Thomas münden
dafür haben viele Royal Fans stundenlang
in der brütenden Mittagssonne gewartet
Prinz Harry der Duke of Sussex näher
wird er den Düsseldorfern kaum kommen
Eintrag ins Goldene Buch der Stadt die
Fans begeistert
wir haben alle so unsere schwarzen
Schafe Familie aber er ist einfach ein
toller Typ und ich hoffe einfach dass
wir glücklich ist ich mag ihn so wie er
ist die Invictus Games für Prinz Harry
ein Herzensprojekt auch für Jens
Niemeyer der als Bogenschütze im
deutschen Team Antritt der
Bundeswehrsoldat Kette aus Afghanistan
mit einer posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörung zurück
Familie die Kinder und die Frauen viel
gelitten in der Zeit war schon sehr
forscht mir weiß auch teilweise egal was
die Familie macht ich habe mein Ding
versucht durchzuziehen eine jahrelange
Therapie und der gemeinsame Sport mit
anderen denen es ähnlich ging halten
Niemeyer wieder in die Spur
ich freue mich eigentlich mit dem Team
so viele wir Momente als möglich zu
haben und das ist auch etwas was er halt
niemand nehmen kann und auch keine
Medaille kann das dir irgendwie geben
das ist einfach ja unbeschreiblich das
Gefühl mit einer großen Eröffnung für
die 500 teilnehmenden Sportler aus 20
Nationen beginnen heute die Spiele eine
große Party und ein Weg mit körperlichen
und seelischen Verletzungen als Soldaten
Polizisten und Rettungskräfte besser
umzugehen
ja gerade läuft die öffnungsfeier den
Viktors Games und Thomas münden ist vor
Ort Thomas welche Botschaft geht von
dieser Feier aus
das ist eigentlich eine ganz einfache
und ganz positive Botschaft stolz vor
Scham gerade uniformierte Kräfte haben
ja wenn sie dann körperlich oder
seelische Verletzungen erleiden oft dann
auch nur das Gefühl dass sie selber
irgendwie daran schuld sein oder dass
ihnen
Unaufmerksamkeit zum Verhängnis geworden
ist und genau dagegen vorzugehen und den
Leuten die hier antreten zu sagen und
den Leuten die hier sind zu sagen ihr
seid nicht Schuld ihr könnt stolz sein
auch das was ihr tut und euer Leben geht
weiter und wir sind alle für euch da
dieser Zusammenhalt Gedanke das steckt
hinter dem Ganzen und das wird Prinz
Harry der nach uns jetzt leider gerade
reden wird wenn wir wieder runter sind
auch so verkünden dass haben wir schon
erfahren
und nach der Eröffnungsfeier kommt Prinz
Harry der denvictus gamesy ans Leben
gerufen hat zu uns nach Mainz ins
aktuelle Sportstudio stellen ja alles
ist vorbereitet für den Duke of Sussex
und Prinz Harry kommt nicht alleine
sondern zusammen mit dem
Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius ab 23 Uhr sprechen wir dann
über die ersten entwickltes Games in
Deutschland
außerdem geht zum Fußball als Gastgeber
der EM im kommenden Jahr muss sich das
deutsche Team nicht qualifizieren
trotzdem stehen Bundestrainer Hansi
Flick und seine Mannschaft im Test gegen
Japan unter Druck
er braucht dringend ein gutes Ergebnis
um seine Position zu stärken mit der
Rückkehr zur Viererkette und günduan in
der chevrolle Mittelfeld wollen sie die
sieglosserie stoppen für uns ist
natürlich wichtig
dass wir jetzt in aller erster Linie ein
gutes Spiel machen und auch mal ein
gutes Ergebnis erzielen was jetzt auch
schon länger ausgeblieben ist wir
starten jetzt auch ähm ja in die heiße
Phase des Jahres und dementsprechend
bleibt nicht mehr viel Zeit in der mit
25000 Fans ausverkauften Arena geht es
um viel ohne Erfolgserlebnisse gegen
Japan und Dienstag gegen Frankreich
könnten Flex Tage auf der Trainerbank
gezählt sein
es war ein gigantischer und historischer
Sieg der deutschen Basketballer gegen
top Favorit USA noch nie stand eine
deutsche Mannschaft im WM-Finale morgen
ist es soweit gegen Serbien geht es um
Gold
grenzenlose Euphorie nach dem
fantastischen Halbfinalsieg gegen die
USA aber gefeiert wurde nach diesem
historischen Erfolg noch nicht
[Applaus]
nein sie haben gegessen und sind ins
Bett gegangen diese Jungs sind
fokussiert sie sehen diese Möglichkeit
die sich nur einmal im Leben bietet das
Finale einer WM
ist
und das wollen sie natürlich gewinnen
gegen Serbien und wieder als
überragendes Kollektiv auftreten
generell erwarte ich ein sehr sehr
physisches Spiel
und ich glaube wir müssen einfach bei
uns bleiben fokussiert bleiben unser
Ding durchziehen und dann haben wir
glaube ich eine gute Chance
könnte wieder im Fokus stehen wie auch
Kapitän Dennis Schröder oder Daniel
Theiss überragend gegen die USA war aber
Andreas Obst und das macht auch die
Klasse dieses Teams aus es ist
unberechenbar
[Applaus]
und das WM-Finale Deutschland Serbien
zeigen wir morgen live im ZDF ab 14 Uhr
die Frauen von Eintracht Frankfurt haben
einen großen Schritt in Richtung
Champions League gemacht im Finale des
qualiturniers setzten sie sich gegen
Juventus Turin im Elfmeterschießen durch
jetzt müssen sie noch um die zwölf
Startplätze für die Gruppenphase spielen
das Männerfinale bei den US Open steht
fest Novak Djokovic trifft auf Daniel
Medvedev der Russe hat überraschen
Titelverteidiger Carlos alcaras aus
Spanien besiegt nach knapp 3,5 Stunden
stand es 3:1 für den Weltranglisten
dritten der bereits 2021 dieses Turnier
gewonnen hatte
so jetzt freue ich mich auf Prinz Harry
danke danke
auch morgen bleiben am Himmel über
Deutschland die Ausnahme sich das Anfang
der Woche ändert erläuter gleich Katja
Hornbach das heute journal läuft an
diesem Abend um 22:45 Uhr mit mariiert
das longka und morgen übernimmt hier mit
riserin auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend derzeit gibt es so wenige
Wolken über Deutschland dass wir beinahe
jeder einzeln begrüßen können zum
Beispiel die kleinen Quellwolken über
der Schwäbischen Alb über dem
Schwarzwald oder auch über dem Hunsrück
und auch heute Nacht bleibt es meist
klar selten bildet sich etwas Nebel die
Temperaturen sinken auf 17 bis 11 Grad
und steigen morgen an der Nordsee auf 24
und am Oberrhein bis auf 33 Grad und
auch morgen gibt's wieder viel Sonne nur
wenige Quellwolken ganz im Süden und
einige Wolkenfelder im Norden oder im
Nordwesten das was ich jetzt langsam
ändern denn Anfang der Woche wird unser
hoch hier langsam weiter ostwärts
abziehen und was räumt dann das Feld für
Tiefs von Westen und die bringen
kräftige Regenschauer und Gewitter mit
und kühlere Luft am Montag erwarten wir
in Deutschland noch Höchsttemperaturen
von 34 Grad aber diese Hitze wird dann
bis zum Mittwoch weiter südostwärts
abgedrängt und dann kommt deutlich
kühlere Luft daran am Mittwoch liegen so
die Höchsttemperaturen an der Nordsee
nur noch bei 18 Grad und in der Nacht
auf Dienstag und Dienstag über Tag wird
es dann kräftige Gewitter geben zum Teil
mit Starkregen und der Mittwoch wird
dann deutlich wechselhafter dabei 18 bis
25 Grad schönes Wochenende